je pense que ceux qui sont avec nous se
posent beaucoup de questions autour de
cet événement qui a annoncé tout à
l'heure en début d'émission en dix ans
il a dû se tromper le monsieur là qui
habillée tout en bleue il à se tromper
c'est pas possible pas la coupe du monde
de rugby des enfants en bourgogne
franche comté laurent creuser ça se
passe pas au japon ça se passe à beaune
et seront mille demain 1000 mais il
c'est un événement qu'a créé mon
conseiller pédagogique sports jean marc
plus où il faut rendre à césar ce qui
est à césar
il est d'ailleurs à beaune en ce moment
en train de peaufiner la préparation
d'événements
ouais et il a initié sa je crois que
c'est la première fois en 2007 et tous
les quatre ans et je crois qu'il a
commencé il y avait 400 gamins 2 cm et
cette fois ci en a 1000 donc ça veut
dire qu'il travaille pas tout seul et a
été capable d'attirer à lui tout un tas
de partenaires donc c'est une très belle
fête
c'est la fête du sport comme on l'entend
à l'école tout à l'heure je faisais ce
rapprochement avec le titre de votre
émission
mais c'est vraiment une des finalités de
l'école faire en sorte de créer des
situations où les enfants apprennent à
vivre ensemble pour que plus tard dans
notre société
ce soit une évidence qu'il faille être
ensemble et travailler ensemble
laurent croset on est vraiment sûr du
vivre ensemble on l'a compris pour des
élèves qui sont à l'école privée ou
publique alors ça se passe à beaune il y
en a qui nous regardent et qui existent
mais pourquoi pas chez moi en franche
comté ou pourquoi pas sur toute la
région ça c'est un exemple qui pourrait
essaimer il faut la volonté sur le
terrain là on a la chance d'avoir dans
mes collaborateurs un ancien rugbyman
qui connaît le milieu du rugby le rugby
qui aurait pu être avec nous aujourd'hui
mais qui pour des raisons d'emploi rien
compris et en préparation passé le noyau
à 2 face à sanofi n'est pas ce que
organiser un tel événement vous imaginez
que c'est pas évident c'est pas
forcément évident on voit quelques
images la voilà en même temps qu'on est
en train de parler de cet événement la
coupe du monde de rugby des enfants à
beaune demain c'est unis que ça se passe
chez nous qu'est ce que c'est que ces
images-là cesser les équipes de il ya
trois ans parce que ça allait je crois
que c'est là la groupe
il ya quatre ans ouais là alors là oui
il y en a il y en a beaucoup moins que
mines dont tous n'étaient pas sur la
photo ce jour là bas ça doit être la fin
de la compétition et toute la journée
ils vont jouer par équipes de cinq six
et ils vont jouer 5 6 minutes ils vont
faire cinq matches le matin cinq matches
l'après midi sept sont des équipes
mixtes
le but c'est pas seulement de gagner 7
participer parce que ce qui est
intéressant dans tous ces événements
vous parlez de la courge de la fête du
vin à oman novembre à abu dhabi avant de
la vendre
il ya très grande course qui est
organisée là aussi les écoles y
participent et ce qui est vraiment tout
dias mans et ce sera la même chose
demain la première fois j ai assisté
c'est de voir tous ces gamins courir
même ceux qui courent pas ou si bien que
les autres qui sont un peu gênés dans
leur corps ils étaient heureux d'être là
ils étaient encouragés par leurs copains
ou leurs copines et c'est bon c'est pas
une obsession chez moi de le vivre
ensemble nous avions de secours est
l'exemple parce que c'est
c'est plus que le sport c'est de
l'éducation physique et sportive et vous
avez raison de le dire c'est plus que le
sport parce que on a vu quelques images
tout à l'heure en fait après la coupe du
monde
les enfants vont avoir à écrire une
histoire avec des personnages racontez
moi parce que j'ai pas tout compris sur
le conseil par sas à commencer par
éduquer déjà toutes les équipes et en à
enfin il n'y a pas autant 25 écoles en
tout qui se sont vus à johnny clegg
voilà enfin johnny clegg la partage en
est là et c'est oui alors justement quel
est le rapport avec la coupe du monde de
rugby des enfants cette photo là bas
parce que je suis le riz l'afrique du
sud se met d'accord avec vous mais mais
mais non on se dit mais ok mais
les enfants qui font la coupe du monde
il pense pas forcément à lorsqu'on leur
a demandé et il était en train de nous
amener les panneaux au moment voilà
téléphoné vendredi de faire la carte
d'identité d'un personnage mythique du
pays qu'ils vont présenter lors dans les
écoles beaunoise un corps gisant près
l'afrique du sud
l'eau les autres l'italie la france bien
sûr
et voilà comme une rareté pour pour pour
l'italie est donc une carte d'identité
sur un personnage légendaire ou célèbres
du pays et dans un deuxième temps avec
le lycée marey qu'à une section des fois
j'espère qu'on y voit l'image parce
qu'il ya des choses qui vont ils vont
écrire un une légende autour de ces
personnages et ça va être publiée sur
sous la forme de d'un livre d'accord est
ce que les équipes gagner quelque chose
il gagne d'abord la joie d'être ensemble
[Rires]
au delà de ça effectivement il y aura un
classement final
il ya aller dans les châteaux poule les
cinq premières places c'est le japon
voilà un autre panneau la kanawa sur un
héros qui s'appelle aux motards aux
jeunes et au japon linge et mollard par
les japonais c'est pas mieux que moi
donc effectivement il ya une remise de
coupe traditionnelle
d'accord c'est vraiment une fête
conviviale il ya beaucoup de gens qui y
est le club de rugby qui participent le
lycée marey pour la publication de ce
livre il ya la viti l'école de
viticulteurs et d'une viticulture avec
des jeunes lycéens qui vont participer à
l'arbitrage donc c'est vraiment un
travail d'équipé c'est ça qui est
intéressant beaucoup de parents d'élèves
aussi c'est ses 22 écoles publiques ces
trois écoles privées c'est maintenant
simple plus de 900 élèves de cm1 et cm2
aussi c'est un bel exemple de vivre
ensemble de lisier tous les enfants
participent ce n'est pas une compétition
sportive comme les autres on l'a compris
derrière un projet éducatif et ça ça
nous plaît vous connaissiez vous la
coupe du monde de rugby des enfants
dominique parce que vous êtes
particulièrement sportif alors oui c'est
ça les deux voient comme plutôt bien le
rugby
oui oui j'en avais entendu parler ce qui
est intéressant dans cette histoire
c'est que c'est de pouvoir réunir en un
seul lieu au même moment autant de
nations et je pense que c'est un tour de
force parce que c'est quand même des
gamins faux les faux les bouger pour les
amener là et puis et puis le rugby c'est
le oui c'est le sport qui par excellence
rapproche les hommes donc en tout cas
six hommes
bel exemple mais aussi l'allemagne où ça
les exceptions mix est très important et
le proportion le seul plaisir quand dans
toutes les équipes choix enfin ça comme
ça quand elles sont toutes mixtes les
équipes super tout cas c'est un grand
moment je suis sûr qu'on en reparlera
sur les écrans connectés faut aussi
remercier le club de rugby de brive
venir justement pour terminer parce que
voilà tout nous ce ne serait pas
possible sans des vrais entre guillemets
pardonnez-moi mais les vrais joueurs de
rugby des vraies équipes et on salue le
talent des rugbymans beaunois et plus
généralement tous ceux qui aiment le
ballon ovale et qui suivent de temps en
temps si les des matches un peu partout
sur les écrans plus ou moins connectés